ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะหมอก็มาเจอกับ
รอง 2 คนนะคะในวีดีโอบีกินเนอร์
ดีจริง
ใครแล้วครูฟ้าขาวันนี้วันอะไร
วันนี้วันนี้จันทร์วันนี้วันจันทร์วัน
จันทร์วันจันทร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันจันทร์
ที่ 20
20 เดือนอะไร
เดือนธันวาคมเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่
เท่าไหร่คะเดือนธันวาคมเป็นเดือนที่ 12
ค่ะปีพตต
ปีพต 2  564
เมื่อปีคศ
2  021
แล้วเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อาทิตย์ค่ะวันอาทิตย์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวัน
อาทิตย์ที่ 19 เดือน
ธันวาคม
เป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือนที่ 12
ค่ะ A พ.ต.ต.
2564 ปีคศ 2  021 หรือแล้วให้ผีวันอะไร
คะพรุ่งนี้วันพุธค่ะวันอังคารวันอังคาร
เอ้ยไปกับกูปลาด้วยวันอังคาร
[เพลง]
วันอังคารที่เท่าไหร่คะวันอังคารที่ 21
ค่ะเดือน
ถ้าเป็นเดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือนที่ 12
ปีพตต
2564 ปีคศ 2  021
น้องแล้วตอนนี้เวลา
กี่โมงแล้วเวลาตอนนี้เวลา 15:00 นหมู่
บ้าน 15:00 นกี่นาทีคะครูฟ้า 7 นาทีค่ะ
บ่ายสามโมง 11 นาทีน
[เพลง]
ร้อนนะ
ร้อนใช่ไหมใช่แล้วนะคะก็วันนี้น้องเราสอง
คนเนี่ยก็จะมีเกมมาเล่นกันใช่ไหมคะมีคำ
ถามไม่มีคำถาม
ครับมีคำหมอลำมาถามเราครูหญิง
ถามครูฟ้า
หนูฟ้าถามครูหญิงใช่ไหมคะ
พอฟังคำถาม
เราจะต้องคิดสมัยกว่าฟ้า
คิตาคิดว่ามี a แล้วก็ดีเนาะเอเอก็คือ
จริงใช่ไหมคะจริงเบก็คือไม่จริง
ไม่จริงตอบผู้หญิงเนี่ยฟังครูฟ้าถามก็คุย
ถึงใช่ไหมก็ต้องคิดคิดคิดคิด
[เพลง]
จริงหรือไม่จริง
เสียง
จริงหรือโกหก
ดายจริงๆแน่จริงก็คือโกหกนะต้องใส่แดก
โอเคใครถามก่อนคือฟ้า
คุณฟ้าก็ได้ค่ะโอเคป๊าถามก่อนได้ค่ะข้อ
ที่ 1 ฟ้าอันนี้เราจะเป็นข้อที่ 1 นะครู
ฟ้าถามอะไรคะ
ว่าอยากถามว่า
ครูฟ้า
สูงหนีขิงยังไม่เสร็จนะค่ะ
สูง
170 เซนติเมตร
จริงหรือไม่จริง
น้อง
ๆไม่จริงครูหญิงถ้าคิดว่า
ไม่จริง
คุยคิดอ่ะกูฟ้าสูง 170 เซนติเมตรเอเอไม่
จริงปะ
นักเรียนคิดว่าไงคะจริงหรือไม่จริง
เรื่องของไม่รู้นักเรียนตอบแล้วนักเรียน
ออกจากดูแล้วจริง
ไม่รู้แต่ครูหญิงคิดไม่จริงค่ะ
เป็นไงคะคือฟ้าครูหมูอาหาร
สูง 170 เซนติเมตรจริงหรือไม่จริง
ไม่จริงหาเรียน
แก่
แล้วไม่จริงครูฟ้าสูงมากกว่า 50 รึน้อย
กว่า
ชิงได้ไหม
ครูฟ้าสูง
น้อยขวา 170 บาทต่อแล้วครูฟ้าสูงเท่าไหร่
คะไม่ได้สูง 170 เซนติเมตรครูฟ้าสูง
167 งู
มีซูมสูงมากๆนะ
คนไป
[เพลง]
ใช่ค่ะ
ผู้หญิงว่าผู้หญิงว่าครูหญิงถามครูฟ้าว่า
ครูหญิงได้นะคะดื่มกาแฟน้องกาแฟก็คือ
อเมริกาโน่ S เพรสโซ่ลาเต้ผู้หญิงเพียง
ดื่มกาแฟกาแฟเย็นนะคะ
มันกาแฟเนี่ยกาแฟ
3 แก้วต่อวัน
หนึ่งวันผู้หญิงดื่มกาแฟ 3 แก้ว
จริงหรือหรือไม่จริง
ครูฟ้าคิด
ครูฟ้าคิดว่า
ไม่ติ่งค่ะไม่จริง
ไม่จริงค้าครูฟ้าคิดว่าไม่จริงใช่ไหมอ่ะ
ไม่จริงแล้วครูฟ้าคิดว่า 1 วันนะคะครู
หญิงดื่มกี่แก้ว
ครูคิดว่า 1 วันครูหญิงดื่ม
1 แก้ว 1 แก้วใส่ไฟฟ้าบอกว่า 3 เนี่ยไม่
จริงกูฟังคิดนึ่งแก้วเนอะอ่ะอ่ะ
มาเฉลยนะคะ 1 วันเนี่ยผู้หญิงดื่มกาแฟ 3
แก้ว
ไม่จริงค่ะ
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงดื่ม 1 แก้ว
1 วัน 1 แก้วพอแล้ว
โหกูฟ้าเก่งมากๆใช่ไหมคิดว่าไม่จริงแล้ว
ก็คิดโห่บ้าน 1 วันเด็ก 1 แก้วชายค่ะไม่
นอนอ่ะครูป่าคือฟ้านะคะค่ะ
ถามว่า
กูฟ้าชอบดื่ม
โค้กซีโร่
โค้กซีโร่ที่โค้กที่ไม่ใส่น้ำพี่ตาลน็อค
ศูนย์เปอร์เซ็นต์น้ำติดโดนซีโร่โค้กซีโร่
หรือว่าเป็นซี่แม็กซ์นี่แหละค่ะจริงหรือ
ไม่จริงหือครูฟ้า
ดื่มโค้กซีโร่
ครูฟ้าช็อตดื่มโค้กเนี่ยคิดว่าจริง
แต่โค้กซีโร่หรอไม่จริงค่ะ
ทำไม
คนไทยคนไทยคนไทยมากๆไม่ชอบโค้กซีโร่ผู้
หญิงก็เลยคิดครูฟ้าก็เป็นคนไทยครูฟ้าน่า
จะไม่ชอบโค้กซีโร่ก็เลยคิดว่าที่กูฟ้าถาม
ว่าครูฟ้าช็อตดื่มโค้กซีโร่ก็คิดไม่จริง
แล้วจริงไหมคะอ่ะ
ยัง
ไม่กินค่ะ
เพลงโทรฟางเออ
ดื่มโค้กซีโร่
ไม่ชอบมากๆค่ะความไม่ชอบอยู่โค้กซีโร่นะ
คะแล้วก็ปล่อยชอบดื่มโค้กไหมใช่ฮะถ้าเป็น
โค้กเป๊ปซี่โอเค
แต่โค้ก
ใช่ค่ะนี้ท่าโค้กซีโร่
จะไปสอบ
ไม่ชอบนะคะแต่ว่าเพื่อนเพื่อนซื้อมาก็ไม่
กินเพราะว่าไปสอบไม่ชอบนะคะนั่นแหละผู้
หญิงเก่งมาก
ข้อที่ 2 ของผู้หญิงเนาะของผู้หญิงถามว่า
ครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะผมใส่รองเท้า
อันนี้รองเท้านะ
รองเท้าเหมือนรองเท้าไหมคะ
ได้อยู่
ซักรองเท้าเพราะว่าจะหมดแล้วไม่เหมือนหรอ
อ่ะนี่เนาะรองเท้านะคะครูหญิงเนี่ยใส่รอง
เท้า
ไซส์
36 นะไม่รู้ EU  36 นะคะ size  36 จริง
หรือไม่จริง
ไม่จริงค่ะสวยคนคิดเร็วมาก
ไม่จริงไม่จริง
แล้วแล้วคิดว่ากูหญิงใส่ไซส์อะไรถ้าครูบา
คิด 36 เนี่ยไม่จริง
ลูกค้าคิดว่าอ่ะแต่ว่า naha ผู้หญิงใส่
รองเท้า size  41
koo ฟ้าได้บอก 36 ไม่จริงก็คิด 41 นะคะ
ที่ 9
ผู้หญิงเนาะใส่รองเท้าไซส์ 36 เนี่ยไม่
จริงนะไม่จริงนะคะ
41 ก็ไม่จริง
หรือ
39 ก็ไม่จริง
แล้วค่ะอีกมั้ยค่ะใส่รองเท้าไซส์อะไรคะ
ผู้หญิงใส่เนี่ย
37 หรือว่า
38 ได้ 7  38 นี่
ตอบถูกนะเก่งมากโอเคครูฟ้าคำถามข้อที่ 3
ค่ะของครูฟ้าคำถามข้อที่ 3 ของกูปลานะคะ
ครูฟ้าชอบ
พ.ศ.
ต่อยมวยสุด
จริงหรือไม่จริงนะครูซ่าชอบต่อยมวยเหรอ
หมีใช่มั้ย
ไม่จริงค่ะครูหญิงรุ้ง
ถึงไหมแล้วโทรฟาชอบต่อยมวยจริงไว้
ไม่จริงอ่ะ
กู้ภัยคิดอยากปล่อยมวยนะแต่ยังไม่เคยต่อย
มวยนั้นอ่ะอ่าไม่เคยฟังม่วนผู้ชายก็เลย
ไม่รู้ใช่ไหมชอบหรือไม่ชอบหน้าๆหัวหน้า
เก่งว่างเลยนะเราเนี่ยถูกถูกถูกๆข้อ
วันที่ 3 เขาที่ตายตามครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะ
ไม่กิน
ไม่กินกระเทียม
กระเทียมนะกระเทียมเนี่ยครูหญิง
ไม่กิน
จริงหรือไม่จริง
ครูขาดอินอะเทียมจ่ายค่ะเอ้อกินคะเถียง
ไม่จริงค่ะไม่จริง 2
ไหนกินกระเทียมกระเทียมจริงหรือไม่จริง
จริงๆถ้าเธอมา
ช้าไปกินข้าวด้วยกัน
3 ที่แล้ว
หญิงก็บอกว่าเล่นกิจกะทิ
ไม่กิจประเทียวอะไรเมนูบางอันมันก็มี
กระเทียมมาใช่แต่ไม่กินไงกูฟังหรอ
[เพลง]
คำว่าหรอ
คุณฟ้านะก็คิดว่าครูฟ้าน่าจะรู้ข้อนี้กู
มาก็จริงๆตอนแรกคิดว่ากูหญิงไม่กิน
กระเทียมนะคะแต่เพราะว่าไปกินข้าวกับผู้
หญิงสามวันที่แล้วแล้วมันมีเมนูที่มี
กระเทียมแต่กูเห็นกินไม่ใช่หรอต้องกิน
แต่งยังไงเอา
ไม่กินก็คือกระเทียมก็ไม่กินหรอนิ
[เพลง]
พายใช่ถ้ามีกระเทียมอยู่ในอาหารก็กับ
เสียงอ่ะกูฟ้าเอาไหมกระเทียมเอาค่ะ
กินได้
อ้ะครูฟ้าข้อที่ 4 ค่ะ
เมื่อกี้มีอะไรอยู่ในหัวบ้างนะ
รูฟ้าเคย
ไม่
นอน
ไม่นอนพี่น้องไม่เรา 3 วันโข
3 วันก็คือ 4 ไม่ใช่
3 วันเนี่ย 72 ชั่วโมงสมัยครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ไม่นอน
72 ชั่วโมงใช่ไหม 3 วัน
จริงหรือไม่จริงอ่ะ
[เพลง]
อ่ะจริงค่ะ
ผู้หญิงคิดว่าพ่อกูฟ้าบอกว่าครูฟ้าไม่ชอบ
นอนไงคุณก็เลยคิดถ้าครูฟ้าไม่นอนนะไม่นอน
เลย 3 วัน
จริง
จริงไหมคะ
ไม่จริงค่ะอ้าว
เสียใจอะไรขนาดนั้นคิด
แล้วครูฟ้าเคยไม่นอนนะไม่นอนนะนานที่สุด
กี่วัน
มีมั้ยมีมั้ย
อ๋อ
[เพลง]
2 วันใช่ไหมคืนไม่ได้นอน 2 วันศุกร์ต้อง
2 วันนี้
พี่เก๋คะขาข้อที่ 4 เนาะของครุยมนะคะข้อ
ที่สี่ก็คือครูหญิงกับครูไฟล์แม่ใส่แว่น
ตาแว่นตาก็คือตาเราเนี่ยสั้นๆตาสั้นก็คือ
ดูใกล้ๆโอเคดูไกลๆเนี่ยมองไม่เห็น
ครูหญิงเนี่ยตาสั้นนะคะตาสั้นเนี่ย
100 บาทลบ 100 นะคะเล็กรบ 100 เมตรหรือ
ว่าจุดหนึ่ง
จุดหนึ่งปะหน้าร้านน่าจะใช่ไหม
เด้งหรือว่า -100 ใช่มั้ยไปเช็คเวลาเช็ค
ตาอ่า
จริงหรือไม่จริง
ไม่จริงค่ะ
ทำไมอ่ะทำไมคิดไม่จริงอ่ะ
ผู้หญิงนะค่าสายตาสั้นมากกว่า 100
กว่า 100 เนาะมาก็เลยกินไม่จริงนะคะจริง
ผู้หญิงสายตาสั้น
ไม่จริงค่ะ
หมึก
ตอนเนี่ย 100
ตอนนี้คิดว่า
เท่าไหร่คะผู้หญิง
250 บาทกว่าฟ้า
250 บาทอ่ะแต่ข้างขวา
250 ข้างซ้ายน้อยกว่าร้อยกว่า
250 บาทเนาะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยก็ตาสั้นใช่ไหมคะดูฟ้าสั้น
เท่าไหร่คะ
ครูฟ้าสั้น 600 ค่ะ Kapook
หมอ
วิทวัสลบใช่ไหมปลุกร้อยเนาะครูป๋า
รอยสายค่ะน้องครูหญิงก็ 250 บาทเล็กครู
ฟ้านะคะเราก็คุยเนาะ
เจาะไม่จริงใช่ไหมพรุ่งนี้บอกว่าสั้น 100
ใหม่ไงไปจริงเนาะวันนี้เราก็มาเล่นเกมคำ
ถามใช่ไหมอือหรือไม่จริง
ไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนเนี้ยเนาะนักเรียนเล่น
กับเราแล้วนักเรียนตอบถูกกี่ข้อสมัยน้า
ผิดกี่ข้อนะคะเจ้าเขามันบอกรอได้เนาะได้
อ่ะใช่ไหมคะวันนี้เราสองคนก็ต้องไปก่อน
เนาะพี่คอนเจอกันใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะอ่ะก็
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ